the whole day is chaotic when you have
four kids like Kim Kardashian and Kanye
West ish gets wild it's really lit and
fun and crazy yep Kim stopped by Good
Morning America on Wednesday and opened
up about all the chaos I mean the other
day my daughter Chicago fell out of her
high chair cut her full-face stitches
had to like you know figure it all out
so stuff happens and it's you know gotta
roll with it so how is little shy doing
she's okay yes big big scar I shy she's
okay Kim recently shared this sweet
family pic of her and her hubby Kanye
with the whole fam writing morning
madness okay so it might be total
madness in the Kardashian West house but
when et caught up with Kim in 2019
she said that adding baby Psalm to the
fam actually rounded things out and I
feel like having four is so much more
Zen
I feel really calm and Zen I feel like
they all love each other the baby really
like brought back like you know my two
older kids would fight a little bit and
now since the baby's here everyone gets
along everyone loves each other
Kim and Kanye had their two youngest
children Chicago and Psalm
via a surrogate anyone that says or
thinks it's just the easy way out is
completely wrong I think it's so much
harder to go through it this way knowing
that I was able to carry my first two
babies and not you know my baby now that
is hard for me so it's definitely a
harder experience than I anticipated
just in the control area that inner
struggle is kind of hard but I'm just
rolling with it and it is what it is so
what Kim and Kanye have more babies
Kim didn't exactly shut down the idea
because I am so busy doing so many other
things I want to make sure each kid gets
so much of my attention I could I would
do even numbers so I could go to more
but I won't
I won't I think that's just like I
I'll go crazy but I think four is the
perfect magic number for me
and she stressed that for her it's all
about making time for her families it's
so important to give the perfect amount
of attention to every kid and so
especially with school now and
everything that I'm doing I really just
can't extend myself beyond this everyone
always asks like what's next and I'm
like I'm just gonna focus and do what
I'm doing I can't do anything else but
on Good Morning America
Kim admitted it takes a lot of
discipline to make it work
I'm very micromanage so I get up at like
5:40 in the gym by 6 really Wow done you
know seven they wake up I get him up at
7:05 breakfast at 7:30 out the door by
seven 55 like it's it's super
micromanage it's like a military
operation yes this is next-level
organized and I am so here for it of
course you can count on et to help you
keep up with all of the Kardashians so
make sure to keep it locked right here
until next time I'm Hallie Stevens bye
for now
[Music]